كان حدثا مهولا مريعا خلف مشاهد فظيعه
دمار وركام وجثث وديار كان لم يسكنها احد
في يوم من الايام انه زلزال مدمر ولكن ليس
كاي زلزال فالهدف هنا جزيره جاوا
الاندونيسيه اكثر الاماكن اكتضاضا بالسكان
على وجه الارض واحد اخطر مواقع النشاط
البركاني في العالم اما الاخطر فهو ان
ضحايا هذه الكارثه تخطوا السته الاف شخص
فما القصه
في السابع والعشرين من مايو للعام 2006
قرابه الساعه السادسه صباحا باغت زلزال
مدمر سكان جزيره جاوا الاندونيسيه فقدم
ضاجعهم وهز بنيانهم ثم اجهز على مراكز
بيعهم ومصادر رزقهم سجل زلزال الذي ضرب
المحيط الهادئ وتركز في جزيره جاوا سته
درجات واثنتين من عشره على مقياس ريختر
ملحقا اضرارا كارثيه بمدينه يوجيا كارتا
الواقعه وسط الجزيره في اقل من دقيقه
انهارت اسطح المنازل وسقط الكثير منها على
رؤوس السكان النائمين كما تهدمت الفنادق
والمباني الحكوميه ما ادخل الناس في حاله
من الفوضى منهم من اوى الى المرتفعات
القريبه خوفا من حدوث تسونامي ومنهم من فر
من مسكنه فيما لم يستطع الكثيرون التحرك
بسرعه كافيه الى بر الامان
تحرك الجيش بامر رئاسي للمساعده في اجلاء
الضحايا في محبه المنظمات المحليه
والدوليه للاغاثه امتلات المستشفيات عن
بكره ابيها بالمصابين الذين بلغت اعدادهم
اكثر من 16 الف شخص فاعلنت الحكومه
الاندونيسيه حاله الطوارئ لمده ثلاثه اشهر
لعده ايام تاليه استمر انقطاع الكهرباء
وامدادات المياه وترك ما يصل الى 200 الف
شخص تحت رحمه الامطار الغزيره والهزات
الارتداديه المستمره دمر زلزال اكثر من 60
الف منزل في المنطقه المنكوبه وقتل
62434 شخصا على الاقل قدر حجم الخسائر
الماديه بنحو ثلاثه مليارات ومئه مليون
دولار فيما ان الاثار التي تركتها الفاجعه
في قلوب السكان وذاكرتهم لا يوجد مقياس
يحدد حجمها
[موسيقى]